[Aplausos]
[Música]
la unión europea' es como el windows de
la política es lenta no funciona bien y
de vez en cuando se bloquea
sin embargo seamos honestos el resto de
alternativas no son mucho mejores y
cuestan mucho más a principios de este
año en visual politics acabamos un vídeo
en el que hablábamos del auge de la
extrema derecha que en aquel momento
parecía imparable y muchos analistas
aseguraban que el presi marcaba el
inicio del fin de la unión europea
durante estos últimos meses todos los
medios de comunicación se han llenado de
trabalenguas como flex it
merziq y exit entre otros
sin embargo este furor euroescéptico ha
durado bastante poco en francia- han
elegido como presidente a emmanuel
macrón que defiende a la unión europea a
capa y espada y lo mismo ha ocurrido en
el resto de países que han tenido
elecciones en otras palabras que la
unión europea está más viva que nunca al
menos por los próximos cuatro años
pero esperad un momento porque las cosas
son mucho más complejas de lo que
parecen
en realidad no todos los euroescépticos
tienen la misma idea de cómo debería ser
europa y de hacia dónde debería avanzar
por ejemplo en manuel macrón defiende
una unión fiscal con impuestos muy
parecidos en todos los estados miembros
esta idea sin embargo no le hace mucha
gracia ni a jean claude juncker ni a
angela merkel por otro lado el ex
presidente de bélgica y presidente del
partido liberal europeo guy verhofstadt
defiende un modelo de unión europea
federal al estilo del de eeuu
y os preguntaréis están de acuerdo todos
los europeístas con este político pues
lo cierto es que no en realidad lo único
que comparten todos estos líderes
europeístas es que la unión europea es
buena pero que es la unión europea y en
que debería convertirse se trata de una
federación o de una confederación cuáles
son los distintos modelos que hay sobre
la mesa hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Música]
y si margaret thatcher tuviera razón
margaret thatcher es algo así como el
elvis presley de los euroescépticos
durante décadas esta mujer que fue la
primera ministra de reino unido durante
los años 80 ha sido el modelo de muchos
de esos movimientos que quieren acabar
con el proyecto europeo
pero nuevamente la realidad vuelve a ser
mucho más complicada que todo eso sí es
cierto que margaret thatcher fue muy
crítica con todos estos procesos de
integración europea en aquella época la
unión europea no existía como tal tan
sólo era una comunidad de países que
compartían unas regulaciones comunes y
por tanto podían comerciar libremente
entre ellos
sin embargo en los años 80 los distintos
gobiernos de los países europeos se
ponen de acuerdo para profundizar más en
esta unión es en esta época cuando se
habla de crear una moneda única y una
serie de nuevas instituciones que luego
en el año 1992 cristalizarían en lo que
se conoce como los acuerdos de
maastricht pero que pensaban margaret
thatcher de todo esto lo cierto es que
si nos alejamos de los estereotipos
históricos y nos leemos sus memorias
encontraremos citas como estos
reino unido nos sueña con una cómoda y
aislada existencia al margen de la
comunidad europea nuestro destino es en
europa como parte de la comunidad ojo
esto no significa que margaret thatcher
estuviera de acuerdo con todos los
políticos europeos simplemente que
frente a aquellos que defendían unos
estados unidos de europa con capital en
bruselas en lugar de washington dc
margaret thatcher defendía un modelo
distinto un modelo confederado
por supuesto queremos ver una europa más
unida y con un mayor sentido de
propósito compartido pero debe ser de
tal modo que se preserven las distintas
tradiciones poderes parlamentarios y
orgullo nacional del país de cada uno
[Aplausos]
antes de seguir tenemos que explicar
cuál es la diferencia entre una
federación y una confederación
un ejemplo de celebración sería eeuu
texas y california tienen sus propios
parlamentos sus propios gobiernos y sus
propias leyes totalmente distintas a día
de hoy la marihuana es legal en
california pero está prohibida en texas
sin embargo si el congreso de washington
dc sacará una ley legalizando el
cannabis automáticamente quedarían
abolidas todas las prohibiciones en el
resto de estados sin embargo en una
confederación los distintos estados
tienen mucha más autonomía
no hay ningún ejemplo de confederación
en el mundo ni siquiera suiza bien es
cierto que en este país los distintos
cantones tienen muchísima autonomía y
hasta impuestos distintos pero esperad
un momento porque eso no significa que
sean una confederación
[Música]
si por ejemplo en el parlamento de berna
aprobasen una nueva legislación para
legalizar la marihuana el resto de los
cantones deberían aceptarla
automáticamente si suiza fuera de verdad
una confederación
todas estas asambleas cantonales
deberían hacer su propia votación para
ver si realmente quieren legalizar el
cannabis o no es decir que en contra de
lo que dice mucha gente suiza es una
federación de libro pero ahora os
preguntaréis qué es europa es una
federación o es una confederación desde
luego no faltan quienes defienden esta
idea de unos estados unidos de europa
ahora mismo el mayor defensor de esta
propuesta es el presidente del partido
liberal europeo guy verhofstadt that we
need to be for europe teme que tenemos
que reformar euro para convertirla en
una auténtica federación con capacidad
no solo en el campo económico sino
también para establecer una defensa una
capacidad de investigación pero
vayámonos a los
a día de hoy los parlamentos nacionales
tienen muchísimo más poder que cualquier
ley que venga de bruselas por ejemplo
hace unos años los europarlamentarios
aprobaron una directiva para que se
prohibiera fumar en los barrios después
cada uno de los países miembros tuvo que
aprobar su propia legislación antitabaco
y sabéis lo que pasó pues que tanto en
austria como en república checa no se
llegaron a aprobar tales leyes
y durante años en los bares y cafés de
praga y de viena podías encenderse un
cigarrillo sin ningún problema mientras
que en madrid o en berlín estaba
terminantemente prohibido es más incluso
el iva el impuesto sobre el valor
añadido que es el principal impuesto que
existe a nivel europeo es distinto en
cada país en españa pagamos un 21% pero
es que en hungría pagan el 27 por ciento
mientras que en alemania no superan el
19% en otras palabras
europa se parecería más a suiza que a
eeuu
[Música]
y al igual que decíamos con este otro
país la unión europea tampoco es una
confederación pura y dura porque pues
porque existen una serie de leyes que
son de aplicación directa desde bruselas
es decir que el europarlamento dicta el
reglamento y los parlamentos nacionales
no tienen que decidir si lo aceptan o no
directamente se aplica sobre los
individuos y os preguntaréis está
funcionando este modelo híbrido de
federación confederal o necesitamos los
eeuu de europa vamos a verlo
y falla en la unión europea' todos hemos
oído hablar de los muchísimos fallos que
tiene esta integración europea pero lo
cierto es que casi todos estos errores
se podrían aplicar también a los estados
miembros por ejemplo la crisis de los
refugiados es cierto que bruselas ha
sido incapaz de sacar una legislación
común para dar asilo a todos esos
ciudadanos que vienen de países como
siria libia o irak pero no nos engañemos
sin ir más lejos los políticos españoles
tampoco han sido capaces de ponerse de
acuerdo en su propio país por un lado el
gobierno nacional de mariano rajoy ha
hecho todo lo posible para no acoger a
los refugiados pero sin embargo el
ayuntamiento de la ciudad de madrid ha
hecho todo lo contrario entonces el
ayuntamiento de madrid va a generar todo
un proyecto de acogida en ese proyecto
de acogida pues vamos a plantear la
necesidad lo primero pues de que tengan
las personas refugiadas un hábitat lo
más importante es que tengan donde vivir
en otras palabras no podemos esperar que
bruselas solucionen los problemas que no
han sido capaces de resolver los
estados-nación porque en política las
fórmulas mágicas no existen pero esperad
un momento porque eso no significa
tampoco que la unión europea sea
perfecta en realidad sí que hay un
montón de problemas propios de esta
institución por ejemplo imaginad que
sois un trabajador autónomo que vive en
hungría y que hace un trabajo para una
empresa en bélgica cuando les manda es
la factura tenéis que incluir el iva o
no
[Música]
la legislación europea dice que no que
no hace falta que en contratos
intracomunitarios no es necesario
incluir el impuesto sobre el valor
añadido pero después cada país tiene sus
propias legislaciones tributarias que en
muchos casos pueden contradecir a las de
bruselas pero no sólo eso qué tipo de
iva deberías aplicar en la factura el de
bélgica o el de hungría todos estos
problemas se podrían resolver si hubiera
una serie de principios básicos
compartidos por todos los países
europeos en materia fiscal pero muchos
estados no quieren ceder soberanía en
este aspecto y nadie se atreve a dar el
paso hasta que no estén todos de acuerdo
vamos podéis imaginar con estas premisas
es muy difícil tomar cualquier tipo de
decisión política así que ahora os
preguntaréis cuál puede ser la solución
para este problema
un club con distintos tipos de miembros
las constituciones tienen una utilidad
permiten que los políticos y
legisladores sepan lo que no se puede
hacer son algo así como un acuerdo de
mínimos de esta forma un gobierno sabe
que puede sacar cualquier tipo de ley
siempre y cuando no viole en la carta
magna del país las constituciones son un
sistema efectivo y se ha demostrado que
funciona
el problema que todos los intentos por
sacar una constitución europea han
fracasado en el año 2005 tanto francia
como los países bajos celebraron sendos
referéndum en los que echaron por tierra
el intento de crear una carta magna
europea años más tarde los políticos de
bruselas se volvieron a reunir para
sacar una versión renovada de este
primer borrador lo que llamaron el
tratado de bruselas de lisboa quería
decir tratado de lisboa en este caso se
trataba de una versión descarada de esta
primera constitución que en realidad no
llegaba a resolver ninguno de los
problemas de integración de los que
hemos hablado antes
lo cierto es que cada país y cada
gobierno tiene distintos intereses y es
prácticamente imposible ponerlos a todos
de acuerdo así que os preguntaréis por
qué no reconocemos estas diferencias
desde la comisión europea han sacado el
llamado libro blanco de la unión europea
en el que dibujan cinco escenarios
distintos de reforma uno de ellos
permitiría que cada estado aceptará
distintos niveles de integración por
otra parte a principios de 2017 el
semanario the economist proponía crear
una unión europea con distintos tipos de
membresías
por un lado tendríamos a los afiliados
premium que compartirían política fiscal
moneda común y política exterior
por el otro otros miembros de clase
plateada que sólo formarían parte del
mercado común y el espacio de libre
circulación otros miembros vamos a
llamarles de categoría bronce sólo
tendrían acceso a unas competencias más
limitadas de esta forma sería más
sencillo convencer a todos los países
para aprobar una constitución europea
por otra parte esta idea de los eeuu de
europa va perdiendo cada vez más
defensores y casi todas las propuestas
van más en esta línea de europa a
distintas velocidades
[Música]
[Aplausos]
mientras tanto en reino unido ya están
empezando a hacer sus planes económicos
tras el break si podrán llegar a hacer
una unión comercial con eeuu hacer clic
en este vídeo para saberlo
y ahora la pregunta es creéis que puede
funcionar este híbrido de confederación
federal con distintas categorías de
membresía o deberíamos seguir intentando
una federación donde todos los estados
europeos tengan las mismas reglas podeis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y por cierto tenemos que
darle las gracias al profesor óscar
sánchez experto en derecho
constitucional en la universidad de
valladolid por habernos asesorado en la
preparación de este vídeo y como siempre
no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribimos al
canal para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]